SPEAKER: With almost 500
sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't
see How Serverless
Helps You Build
Secure Scalable Apps,
then stay tuned,
because here's a rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When you're building
a cloud application,
security is always on your mind.
It takes a constant
effort to stay ahead
of the threat vectors,
which can easily
burn up engineering time.
Thankfully, serverless
offerings can help cut down
the amount of effort you need.
Vulnerabilities can exist in
almost every stage of a tech
stack, starting with
hardware all the way up
to your application code.
With serverless, everything
below your application code
is managed by Google without
any actions needed on your part.
While you're still responsible
for the security of your code,
GCP has a few tools to help
make it a little easier on you.
First, Cloud Functions
has just released support
for max instances
configuration, which
allow you to reduce
your vulnerability
to both denial of
service attacks
as well as a hug of death,
where you might inadvertently
DOS your own back ends
without knowing it.
There's also improved
budgets and budget alerts,
which can help prevent
against DOS attacks designed
to exhaust your resources.
Next, Cloud Functions has
just rolled out support
for environment variables.
So instead of
leaking credentials
by putting them
directly in your code,
you can manage them from a
separate console interface.
And finally, new IAM
controls grant the ability
to specify which
users have access
to run an interface with
what Cloud Functions, meaning
you can create microservices,
which instead of being
available to the outside
world by default,
can be limited to only
interact with other systems
inside your application.
Now this is just a sampling
from the main talk.
If you're interested in a
larger list of vulnerabilities
as well some great demos
from NPM and Intrinsic,
check out the full talk linked
in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]